welcome back to the hillybilly decline
section and you will be delighted to
hear that
the decline section is also so exciting
as well as contain lot of tricks just
like the accepted one
so after our move order E4 C6 Bishop C4
D5 and Bishop to B3 in my last episode
we have a look at the accept variation
and what to do if your opponent continue
with Pawn takes E4 but as you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows black and
various ways to decline this Gambit and
let's find out how we can conquer them
[Music]
thank you
let's start with the most trickiest one
if I and I must say that whenever my
opponent plays this
I think there's a trick around the
corner
the moon which I am going to recommend
against this start with Knight to F3
and black has three choices
amongst them if you look at the database
here Bishop to G4 is by far the most
popular choice
but I can't tell you how many people has
fallen for this as now white can simply
win upon in the opening stage
the line goes as follows Pawn takes D5
C takes D5
now you play H3 so if Bishop tried to
run away then G4 and then we can take on
E5 so black response is false he has to
take on F3 and after Queen captures F3
every single move is attacking the pawn
Knight F6 what else and now we keep the
pressure more with Knight to C3
and after this no matter whatever black
plays he is going to lose the ball
for example if he plays the move d4 then
we can simply Lop off on B7 and after
something like Knight to D7 and Knight
to D5
apart from winning the pawn we can also
create the pressure on the F7 which is
not easy to dealt with
all in all I think black is already
busted just within the 11th move
okay that is D4 what about the most
natural move E4
and this is where the big trap comes
guys as we have this nice but rare move
Queen to fi
and suddenly we have three attack on the
D5 Pawn which can no longer defend it
well black can try to move G6 here but
white has equally nice reply namely
Queen to if I check and it doesn't
matter however Black Blocks let's say
Queen to E7 then we can exchange
everything Queen takes Bishop takes
Knight takes and the end result is we
are coming out as a complete Pawn up
so this is one of the high profile trick
exists in this bishop to G5 variation
okay let's move on to the second choice
D capture Z4 played in roughly 350
leeches games
big blunder and I think you have spotted
instantly yup Knight captures E5 looking
at Juicy F7 Square and believe it or not
black is already hard-pressed just
within the opening stage
by far the most popular choice is Bishop
to E6 which is already a big blunder as
after the simple continuation
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen check
G6 and Knight captures G6
no matter however black plays he get a
completely lost position
for example the best reply black and
blue over here is Knight to F6 attacking
Our Queen and after our Queen to H3
black can move the rook and save it but
after Queen to E6
Bishop to E7
now you exchange everything on E7
and then Castle on the king side
whereupon if you count the material yup
no surprise is two Pawn up Advantage
just within the 13th move of the game
the second move Knight to at six doesn't
solve the problem as we can lash out
with D4 and our threat is very simple we
want to take this Knight and then take
on F7
something which black has to respond
immediately
now recently I have beat a 2100 very
quickly where my opponent played some
logical moves Bishop to D6 so his idea
is that if you take my knight I am going
to take your knight as well and this is
exactly happen in the game Bishop takes
at six Bishop takes E5 and now the sting
in the tail Queen to H5
a double attack and it's not easy to
bury all these tracks for example in the
game my opponent tried to defend
everything with Queen to F6
but after the simple continuation Pawn
takes E5 Queen takes at six and queen
takes F7
black king remained in the center high
and dry and white get all the fun from
here
the third move I want to consider is
Queen to G5 which is a kind of elephant
Gambit territory but it's a worst one as
in this variation black king stuck in
the center and the line I am going to
recommend goes like this you first take
on F7
King to E7 now if you play D4 attacking
the queen
then after Queen takes G2 you simply
Park your Rook on the F1 Square
after Bishop to H3 Bishop to C4
white has defended everything but the
big time problem for the black Camp is
his King is a clear-cut Target in the
upcoming middle game
what has a simple plan he wants to take
out the queen side PCS and castle on the
queen side
last if you think that hang on but isn't
black can take on H2 and attack your
Rook
well this is a trap black and fall for
and the continuation is very simple you
play Queen to H5 pinning down that
Bishop
and after a sample line G6
Queen to H4 check Knight to F6 Bishop to
G5
Bishop to G7 white has this winning move
Knight to G4
so not only we are attacking three times
on F6 but this is also hitting the queen
and after Queen to D6 the simplest move
in the world
you take the piece and get a complete
opening advantage
the second move I want to consider here
is D4 which I most oftenly faced in my
online Blitz Games
and against this my planning of campaign
is very simple
you continue with D3
and if you have watched my attacking
chess Gambit against Scandinavian I have
recommended this plan
where white plays the move F4
followed off with Knight to F3 and
castle on the king side whereupon he get
tremendous attack on the black king
not so surprising there are some traps
here as well for example if you check
the database by far E5 is the most
popular choice
and when we play F4
what else
Bishop to D6 defending the E5 Pawn
well I'm afraid this is a big time
Mistake by black as now white can
unleash the following sequence
Pawn takes E5 Bishop takes E5 and after
Queen to H5
again and again in this line this queen
Moon can create the double attack
one of my recent game against the 1900
rated player continue with Queen to E7
defending both the threat
but what has been missed out is what has
this nice spawn grabbing move
Bishop captures F7
and the big point is if black doesn't
take it then his King going to be
misplaced and even though Queen captures
F7 leads to a completely lost position
after Queen captures IFA check Queen to
E7 and queen captures D4 where the end
result is White is coming out as a two
point Advantage which is almost close to
the winning one
foreign
are you really enjoying so far
well let's continue the third black
option
namely Knight to F6 and I think this
Knight to F6 and E6 leads to the French
territory whereupon white is well said
to meet black on the king side
for example against all of this line I
am going to recommend the move E5 and
after Knight to D7 we get this Advanced
French kind of structure with D4
and the point is after E6
as white has not committed the Moon
Knight to F3
I am going to propose this nice idea
starting with Knight to E2
the big point is we keep our F Pawn
flexible so that we can push it as far
as it goes and as you will see this
factor is very critical in the upcoming
middle game
well to understand the overall plan from
the white perspective I like to show you
one of my recent game against a
candidate Master where I crossed him
very quickly within the opening stage
my opponent lash out here with C5
and obviously enough I want to keep my
punch in with C3
and now he start pressurizing with
Knight to C6
okay no issues after Bishop to E7 as
black is trying to Castle on the king
side
the key thing you have to remember
yup F4 and if allowed then we will
definitely play the move F5
please remember if your opponent plays
G6 you can even think of G4 and F5 and
get some quick attack on the black king
side
at this point my opponent indeed Castle
which allows what I want to do namely F5
okay we have few exchanges on the board
C captures D4 C captures D4 now we play
Queen to B6
so his threat is as the Deep Pawn is
spin he wants to take on E5 so I park my
king in the corner
and now Knight to E5 attacking the
bishop
now the key root you have to remember is
as this bishop is not well placed on
this diagonal we are going to put on
this lovely Square
whereupon it can straight away
participate on the king side attack
for example my opponent didn't like the
idea of F6 so he continued with e
captures F5
I played a nice intermediate move Knight
to C3
and after he defend with Queen to C6 now
I gobble up the F5 Pawn
well from here onwards white attack just
crashed on black and you will be amazed
how quickly this happened
as my opponent tries some Queen side
activity with Knight to C4
I responded with Rook to H5 a cheap
threat which my opponent defended with
G6
but I am very proud for my next move
even though it is not liked by engine
namely Queen to D3
black cannot take the Rook as there is a
mate threaten on at seven so my opponent
played Bishop to B4
I reveal my whole idea that is swinging
the queen on the king side
and after King to h8 and Rook 2 at 6.
the final mistake happened of the game
that is rooked to E8
probably he thinks that he wants to
bring down this bishop or the Knight to
protect his King
but in order to achieve that he made a
big mistake
as what can by force win the material
with Queen to H4 attacking on that seven
Knight to a f8 defending
and when you're attacking you don't want
to be mad and just looking at one side
of the board sometimes tactics do occurs
on the other side
well I hope you indeed see the moon
Bishop to H5
it's curing the queen and Rook so that
after B5
Bishop takes B5 Queen to E6 I take the
Rook
and when my opponent recaptured my next
move forced the resignation
did you see it yup the simple but very
effective Knight captures D5 whereupon
this Knight is going to create havoc on
the king side
and all together this position is
completely hopeless for the black camp
so remember this new fresh idea
do not play Knight to F3 rather play
Knight to E2 and push your F Pawn
further which give white a amazing King
side attack
last but not least what to do against
the movie six
well no surprise is yep we are going to
play E5
and create this Advanced friend
structure which gives white a space on
the king side
and the good thing about this line is
black has wasted a move with C6 and then
he has to go C5 so in a way he is
wasting a big tempo
okay C5 the most popular choice
and since black is threatening the music
for my recommendation is you start with
C3
whereupon black has two major choices
if we continue with the routine moves
such as Knight to C6 then we can easily
erect our Pawn structure with D4
and after a sample line C captures D4 C
captures D4 Bishop to B4 check Knight to
C3 and Knight to E7 where black is
trying to Castle quickly on the king
side
which at first side looks so good but
this is exactly playing into the White
Hand
you have a very simple plan first you
arrange the bishop on this nice diagonal
and after Bishop to D7 and the Moon
Knight to F3
this is what I have covered in my French
Wing Gambit territory all white wants to
do is
he wants to play H4 and Knight to G5
where upon some sacrifices on the spawns
and black is ill advised to go on the
king side
so you can find out more of this kind of
tactical patterns
by watching my French Wing Gambit
tutorials
to just give you a sample at this point
black cannot Castle as we have this
deadly quick gift coming up
and if black accept this then after
Knight to G5
he cannot play King to G8 due to Queen
to H5 and if King to G6 then S4
finish the black
well the H5 is coming up and if he plays
F5 then even though we can continue with
H5
King has only one space to go afterwards
yup the simple move Knight to E6
grab the black sweetie and in fact the
key
so it is very obvious that if black
continue with his normal French defense
structure and goes on the king's side
then white attack is just waiting there
to crush enemy King
foreign
last but not least what happens if black
continue with C4
well no issues we are going to play
Bishop to C2 and our planning of
campaign will remain same
sooner or later we are going to look out
for the move d4
there is a high profile game from the
database goes like this black plays
Knight to C6 attacking the pawn white
defined with the queen
black renewed the threat and finally
white grabbed the space with F4 as well
as defend the E5 Pawn
okay black plate Knight G2 E7
trying to reroute the Knight
finally why deliver this thematic break
D4
and if allowed then this Pawn chain can
be dangerous for the black
so black immediately chop it off with
the N percent
white recapture
and after Knight to fi
some simple moves Knight to F3 Bishop to
C5
stopping white to Castle
so why try to attack this bishop with
Knight to D2
his idea is to play Knight to B3
so black censored and get out of the
attack with Bishop to B6
anyways Knight to B3 has been played
and
this is what you need to understand in
this line
what really white wants to do is
flonking this juicy Knight on D4
where it cannot be shaken and upcoming
middle game slash end games are always
superior for the whites
this has exactly happened in this game
look how easily white achieved this
black castles
now we have some exchanges
Bishop takes F5 Pawn takes a fire Bishop
to E3
black plays Bishop to E6 which allow y
to create more exchanges
Bishop takes Queen takes
Knight to D4 and after Knight takes and
the Moon Knight takes D4
this is what I was talking about
so we have a middle game where white has
a supreme Knight on D4 where black has
absolutely bad Bishop sitting on E6
and with some careful play I think this
is definitely a great position to play
as a white
just for your knowledge
you will be surprised that engine gives
plus 1.8 advantage to the White
which is obviously the huge one from
this position
that's it guys I hope with these two
lectures now you are confident enough
to play this hillybilly attack in the
tournament practice
the good point I like about this line is
it doesn't matter whether black accept
the pawn or declined it
in almost all the lines not only white
can get some cool tricks and traps
but overall white get a tremendous
attack on the black king
something which we are really looking
forward against a passive Karo Khan
player
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care